let's talk about this this series finale
such a highly anticipated season series
finale
amena deal becomes god in the end we're
gonna go in
[Laughter]
what what went through your mind
when you you realized that's what was
going to happen one i was just
uh pleasantly surprised um
but i think also you know taking a step
back um you know and just taking a look
at the show uh
i i hope it's okay that i say you know
just based on um who these characters
are it makes sense he's been groomed in
in the family business ever since he was
created but as
i think happens sometimes that person
that's been groomed to take over
uh doesn't want the job and has to go on
their journey to come all the way back
around and realize that
um they're perfect for the job and that
maybe they can run the business slightly
you know uh different than that than
than how
the parents ran it
i think you said it perfectly because
actually joe and ildie said amena deal
was actually the god
right yes that it did actually make
perfect sense
overall what did you think about
how the series ended
i thought the series ended really well i
mean i've been nervous to say that
because it's not really up to me it's
not up to us right um i uh the fans will
let us
the fans will let us know
if we have ended the series in a way uh
that makes them happy in my opinion i i
think they did an absolutely excellent
job of wrapping up everyone's storylines
and even leaving some storylines a
little open-ended um but in a satisfying
way so i feel like every character
really got something nice in the end i i
really do yeah speaking of nice in the
end we had talked about this so many
times but amena deal
and linda's son charlie did end up
getting his wings
yes
what took so long
uh i don't know
i don't know um but you know uh it was
fantastic
and i absolutely loved that moment um
uh you know i think it's you know i've
joked about this but i think it's one of
those things where as parents you know
of course we want our children to be all
that they want to be but we all have our
secret you know you know kind of secret
things inside of us that you know that
we're hoping and so i think amenity was
just like every other mom and dad and
just wanted his his son to be a
celestial so they have something in
common something to talk about something
that you know amenities can um teach him
about his powers
um and you know to do it with rachel was
just a blast that that entire story arc
uh with uh rachel was so much fun
chloe and lucifer did get quite the
ending we see chloe and she's on her
death bed and then when she dies amena
deal as god asks if she's ready to cross
over
what was it like to tape that scene with
lauren it was fantastic because that was
my last scene that was my last day
so uh to be able to do that with lauren
who's someone that um she's someone that
i just admire and look up to
she's a phenomenal human being to do
that last scene with her as my last time
as a mena deal was fantastic it meant so
much to me and lauren's performance is
just
uh breathtaking um
uh but it was fantastic it was it was
just
oh
so so so
i won't say heartbreaking because it's a
it's a happy ending um so i'll just say
uh it was
really charged highly emotional um
i loved it yeah what part of the finale
made you the most emotional in a good
way was it that moment was it another
moment
it was actually another moment the
episode that really went through me was
actually episode nine
and
my it was my last scene with tom
and it's the scene where lucifer has
called
a mena deal to the bar
the bar is empty that's where you first
met
amena deal
and uh he shows up there to tell
lucifer that he's decided to become god
and they have that final scene over the
piano uh that was my last scene with tom
um
that was really emotional uh that day we
were both a mess um
uh i'm actually getting
choked up talking about it but it was
just it was really really emotional um
um i loved that guy and we started the
show together and and i'll never forget
um uh starting that show on hollywood
boulevard
and uh being new dads together not new
dads but uh single dads uh together and
and
um
what it meant for both of us to be
um raising girls and uh it was just it
was just fantastic and i loved that guy
and
um that was the that was the final scene
between him and i and that was
the hardest day that i've ever had to
film so wow ever in your entire career
yeah
yeah wow and you've done a lot so that's
saying something yeah it was um
it was a bittersweet day now we're all
gonna have um
these memories and this show and
this journey close to our hearts forever
is your daughter a fan of lucifer do you
let her watch or is she too
well here's the thing um i didn't let
her watch uh for the longest time and
then i found out behind my back uh about
a year ago that she was uh
you know um over at her mom's place uh
uh checking the show out on
netflix so
uh that's out of the bag she does like
the show even though she's too young for
the show
um she give you ideas that she wants or
is she like
oh we gotta we gotta get a mena deal to
do this like does she ever give you
input
no i think uh she usually winds up
talking the most about maize you know
uh love that maze of course right she
thinks maize is badass and uh loves the
way she dresses and you know her her
crazy fashion sense um uh that's that's
that's who my daughter pays more
attention to uh so which is the way it
should be